Speaker 1: Let's go next to well, where are
we going to go next?
Because we really have quite a situation happening
on the phone lines.
Let's go to Grant from Ohio.
Grant, welcome.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Dave is taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 2: Also.
Speaker 1: And Grant we've you've got to turn
off those discord bookings.
You've got to do do not disturb turn off notifications.
You know, whatever it is that needs to be
done, we got to do it.
Speaker 2: All right.
Now.
Um.
Well, hey, I was wondering.
If there was any updates with the markets.
A criminal investigation of a possibly sex
trafficking.
I know it's been going on for quite some time.
Speaker 1: You know, I just saw a story this
morning and I just didn't have time to look
at it in detail.
It's a Daily Beast story from yesterday, actually,
which is called eight.
Sources say the feds are not done with Matt
Gaetz.
And these eight sources told The Daily Beast
that the investigation is still very much
alive and that Matt Gaetz is not out of the
woods.
That's this article, you know, and that's
the eight sources that they have.
I don't know any more than that, but that's,
you know, 12 hours old at this point.
So I think that's the newest info you're on.
Speaker 2: I just saw an NBC poll or says
he's going to win his district again.
Oh, of course.
And I think it also said the district's been
red since at least 30 years ago.
Speaker 1: So it's been a long time.
Oh, he's absolutely going to win.
Yeah.
No, I think listen, what we know is he's a
horrible person.
He may have committed crimes.
And there's currently a very serious investigation
into that.
Speaker 2: You know, it's just kind of kind
of sad.
And then another or I don't know of another
very personal and also professional question,
do you ever plan on writing any books?
Well, I don't know about anything or politics.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm sort of working on a
proposal now, and I have so many things going
on that that it's tough to finish it and move
on to the next step.
But I am in the middle of a proposal and as
soon as I have something to announce on a
book, I will.
Speaker 2: All right.
Well, thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, Grant.
Thank you.
There is Grant from Ohio, very, very respectful
in every way which we love.